das ist leider auch ein Regierungsmodell
dieser Ampel es ist etwas entschieden
worden dieser Beschluss in der Not
entschieden worden dieser Beschluss ist
in großen Teilen zurückgenommen worden
wie lange kann eine Ampel das den Leuten
noch zumuten allein dieses Hin und Her
ich glaube dass man den Leuten diesen
politikmodus eigentlich gar nicht mehr
zumuten kann ich glaube wenn die Ampel
Beschlüsse trifft dann muss sie dahinter
stehen weil man nur so den Leuten ja
auch erklären kann wir machen das weil
wir glauben daran wir glauben dass es
richtig ist und dann geht es natürlich
nicht dass ganz oft dann einer der
Partner oder ein Minister rausgeht und
sagt nee ich glaube daran aber nicht ich
glaube das ist falsch und das ist
schädlich wie sollen die Leute dann
verstehen warum man bestimmte Dinge
macht in dem Fall war es so dass sie
dann rausgegangen sind und gesagt haben
nein diese beiden Maßnahmen die wollen
sie nicht haben diese beiden
Sparmaßnahmen sonst macht es immer die
FDP genau also oft und ich verstehe dass
in dem Fall das auch einen sachlichen
Hintergrund hatte bei der Kfz Steuer das
hätte relativ viel Bürokratie produziert
wenn man diese Erleichterung gestrichen
hätte insofern bin ich auch immer dafür
wenn man merkt dass man Fehler gemacht
hat dass man dann sagt okay wir gehen
dahinter wieder zurück aber
gleichzeitig finde ich kann es jetzt
eben nicht sein dass die Ampel jetzt
noch mal dahinter zurückgehen und alles
streicht weil das zeigen würde dass sie
umfällt dass sie sich unter Druck setzen
lässt von der Straße und das wäre ein
schlechtes Signal und ich glaube aber
für die Zukunft nicht für die Zukunft
muss man dahinkommen dass man hinter
seinen Beschlüssen steht und zwar
geschlossen nur kurz was dazu
sagen und dann Herr
öerst es sind gerade zwei Begriffe
gefallen in dem was Sie gesagt haben wo
es bei mir innerlich so ein bisschen
aufmuckt das eine ist dass man immer
verlangt Parteien sollen auf jeden Fall
immer geschlossen auftreten wo ich sagen
würde das zu verlangen ist eigentlich
eine Absage an den demokratischen
Prozess und auch dass man der Straße
nicht nachgeben soll das kann kan man
auch genau umgekehrt betrachten und
sagen das ist doch gerade momentan das
was passiert eigentlich auch mal wieder
ein positives und erfrischendes Signal
nach außen weil es doch zeigt dass in
Berlin die Ohren offen sind für das was
die Leute wirklich bedrückt und dass ein
Protest zumindest wenn er solche
Dimensionen annimmt und das ist eine
demokratische Meinungsäußerung auch
Auswirkung haben kann also ich glaube
wenn jetzt überhaupt gar nicht darauf
eingegangen würde wenn man das alles nur
abschmettern würde wäre das Signal nach
draußen wesentlich fataler und würde
viel viel mehr Schaden anrichten als
wenn man jetzt auch bereit ist ein
Fehler zu ben Herr öem mir ist gleich
dran sie sind einverstanden wenn ich
Clemens fus unbedingt noch begrüße und
nicht nur begrüße sondern ihm sofort die
erste Frage präsentiere Chef des ifo
Instituts sie haben gesagt sie sind
verwundert gewesen Herr Fust über diese
überproportionale Belastung ausgerechnet
der Bauern ist die in ihren denn jetzt
zurückgenommen Entschuldigung ist es
jetzt okay und sagen Sie es ist nicht
mehr einer recht kämpferischen Gruppe
die auf der anderen Seite aber ja
überproportional tatsächlich belastet
war noch also ist es jetzt zumutbar äh
also es sind zwei Dinge die mich
überrascht haben das eine
überproportional wir hatten ungefähr 900
Millionen Belastung für die Bauern und
das erste Sparpaket kommt jetzt drauf an
wie man zählt das waren ja so 17
Milliarden also eine Gruppe mit 1% der
Wirtschaftsleistung kriegt 5% der Last
aufgebürdet da muss man mal sagen klar
das muss in der Demokratie verhandelt
werden wer zahlt was aber da fragt man
sich was haben die jetzt verbrochen dass
die sozusagen so einen großen Anteil äh
aufgebürdet bekommen der andere Punkt
ist dass ja das Thema Agrardiesel
eigentlich in die Debatte kam weil man
sagt das ist klimaschädlich das ist eine
klimaschädliche Subvention und das war
für mich der zweite Fehler also ich im
Prinzip ist das richtig dass MAN Diesel
nicht subventioniert ist vollkommen
richtig äh weil das weil wir wollen ja
weg von den fossilen Brennstoffen das
Problem ist nur das darf man jetzt nicht
vermischen mit einem konsolidierungspakt
beim CO2 Preis da sagen W der
Bevölkerung Leute ja wie Benzin wird
jetzt teurer aber ihr kriegt das Geld
zurück das heißt wenn man sowas machen
will mit der Landwirtschaft und sagt ja
Leute aus klimagründen sollte nicht mehr
so viel Agrardiesel verwenden da muss
man ihnen sagen ja wir verteuern das
jetzt oder wir nehmen die Subvention weg
aber ihr kriegt das Geld zurück das
waren für mich jetzt zwei Fehler die man
gemacht hat und da da sage ich ich bin
überrascht weil das weiß meine das sind
ja keine Anfänger das wusste doch die
wussten doch alle Beteiligten dass das
unter keinen Umständen durchgeht dass
dann die Trecker Fahrten kommen da da
musste man ja kein Prophet sein um um
das V zuusagen das hat mich wirklich
gewundert war das ein Schnellschuss ich
meine manchmal ist es ja so in der
Politik da sagt man okay wir machen mal
zwei Kürzungen ne dann gibt's eine
schöne Demonstration nehmen eine zurück
dann wird sowas antizipiert aber aber
das waren das war mal kam zu dicke aus
meiner Sicht deshalb habe ich gesagt das
ist überproportional ändert glaube ich
nichts daran dass man sagen muss
klimapolitisch ist richtig wir müssen
weg von der Subventionierung fossiler
Brennstoffe aber das dürfen man nicht
verbinden mit Konsolidierungspaket jetzt
sind die beiden Politiker wieder dran
erste Frage noch mal Herr östemier ich
habe sie nicht vergessen wo würden Sie
denn sparen und warum haben sie dem
Bundesfinanzminister der offensichtlich
von all diesen Dingen nicht sofort eine
Ahnung hatte nicht andere Sparvorschläge
gemacht ein ich will erstmal die
Koalitionsspitzen auch in Schutz nehmen
sie müssen den Haushalt sanieren der der
Haushalt war nicht verfassungskonform es
gibt das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes und das ist
die Regierung natürlich gebunden und
muss die 17 Milliarden kurzfristig
einsparen die anderen Wege gingen nicht
die FDP sagt hten sie gespart äh die
Schuldenbremse wird nicht ausgenommen
sie sagt keine Steuererhöhung und
dadurch ist der Spielraum klar wir
müssen sparen ich habe ein Beitrag
geleistet dass dieser Kompromiss
zustande kommt ist dank meinem Haushalt
ermöglicht worden von den mehrinnahmen
die wir bekommen als Ausgleich für
Offshore Windenergie für die Fischerei
verzich die auf ein Anteil und stell den
zur Verfügung um das gegen zu
finanzieren also ich leiste meinen
Beitrag damit es gelöst wird lass mich
nur mal eins sagen ich glaube das
Problem an diesem Beschluss war dass man
nicht zu Ende gedacht hat dass der nicht
im luftleeren Raum passiert sonder der
trifft auf eine Gesellschaft die
coronaamüde ist es trifft auf eine
Gesellschaft die mit dem Krieg in der
Ukraine zu tun hat wo manche sich fragen
muss das sein ist das richtig ist das
falsch er trifft auf eine Gesellschaft
die mit dem Kampf gegen die Klimakrise
hier und da überfordert ist und dann
kommt noch das und top und die Landwirte
Landwirte sind zurecht beliebt in
unserer Gesellschaft davor war die Sache
mit der Gastronomie und mit der mehr
wertsteuer und das war wenn man so will
der Tropfen der das fast zum Überlaufen
bringt aber ich bin jetzt wirklich nicht
ein Freund davon dass man immer die
Verantwortung bei den Vorgänger und
Vorgängern sucht aber das Fass habe
nicht ich gefüllt das fast da haben
schon auch viele meiner
christdemokratischen Kollegen viel
gefüllt und deshalb will ich einfach
noch mal sagen lassen Sie uns doch nach
vorne gerichtet das zum Anlass nehmen
jetzt mal zu überlegen wie kann das
eigentlich sein dass die Bäuerin und
Bauern von den Produkten die sie leben
produzieren hervorragende Produkte nicht
leben können das hat was mit uns in der
Politik zu tun Mangel der
Verlässlichkeit es hat aber auch was mit
den Verbraucherinnen und Verbrauchern zu
tun dass sie als Bürger sagen wir wollen
Tierschutz wir wollen Artenschutz wir
wollen Klimaschutz aber beim Einkaufen
nicht so einkaufen und das alles müssen
wir jetzt in Angriff nehmen so hat aber
tatsächlich auch was mit den Preisen zu
tun Herr wüst ich muss sie auch noch mal
nerven mit der Frage wo würde die Union
denn wenn Sie jetzt den Kanzler stellte
in dieser Situation bei den Bauern
gespartt haben damit es fair ist damit
es eben genau einen fairen Ausgleich
gibt Fredrich März hat an einer
Versammlung am 8 januar in Meschede
gesagt er verspreche den Bauern eben
nicht dass diese KFZ Steuerbescheinigung
agradiieselsteuer auf alle Zeiten bleibt
aber er sagt wir müssen Euch natürlich
eine Alternative anbieten wenn ihr nur
Traktoren mit Agrardiesel fahren könnt
dann können wir euch jetzt nicht
aufbürgen dieen Agrardiesel nicht mehr
gestützt zu bekommen so hier ist bitte
Ihre Antwort wo hätten sie sie denn
vorgeschlagen soll die Regierung
unbedingt auch den Bauern damit es fair
ist eine Kürzung vorschlagen erstmal ist
richtig was Friedrich Merz sagt und das
macht die ganze Absurdität der Idee ja
offensichtlich es wird mit Klimaschutz
argumentiert die Bauern sind aber
zwangsverbraucher die fahren ja nicht
aus Jus und Dollerei mit ihrem Schlepper
um die Kirche rum sondern die müssen auf
den Acker und damit arbeiten und
deswegen ist das Gerechtigkeitsempfinden
auch verletzt und wer sagt denn dass die
landwi hier jetzt einen großen Beitrag
überhaupt leisten sollen sie leisten ja
schon einen Beitrag ich habe es schon
mal gesagt die Zuschüsse für die
Unfallversicherung werden werden
abgesenkt das heißt die Beiträge für die
landwirtschaftlichen betriee Betriebe
werden steigen die GAK die Gemeinschafts
Aufgabe zwischen Bund und Ländern für
den ländlichen Raum wird gekürzt das
trifft auch wieder direkt und indirekt
Landwirte bei der Mehrwertsteuer
porchallerung wird was gemacht zu alldem
haben sie nichts gehört da sind keine
Trecker Züge durch die Republik Gefahren
nicht weil man das toll findet sondern
weil man sagt okay wenn gespart werden
muss sind wir dabei die Ampel tut so als
müsste sie ein Wunderwerk vollbringen
beiem 470 Milliarden Bundeshaushalt 17
Milliarden einzusparen ist kein
Pappenstil geschenkt aber wir haben in
den landeshaushalten auch sparen müssen
wir hatten etwas mehr Zeit weil wir
nicht knallauff Fall unsere ganze
verfassungswiedrige Haushaltspolitik um
die Ohren geschlagen gekriegt haben aber
wir haben eben auch gespart das ist
regierungshandwerk und die Stimmung die
Herr öst mir zurecht beschreibt die
fällt nicht vom Himmel ja natürlich die
Pandemie die Kriege die
Auseinandersetzung im Nahen Osten alles
richtig aber es ist auch der Politikstil
der Ampel die einfach nicht zu Ruhe
kommt da regieren drei zusammen die in
Wahrheit nicht zusammen passen und wenn
man mal mit den Kolleginnen und Kollegen
vertraulich spricht auch eigentlich
nicht mehr miteinander wollen und daran
sind die Leute auch krank wenn man einen
Kompromiss machen muss der alle
gleichmäßig gich gichmäßig betrifft okay
dann kann man das erklären aber wenn man
den Leuten das vor Latz knallt weil man
selber wieder Woche um Woche nicht
miteinander klar kommt wie wir es oft
erleben dann gibt es diese Probleme wir
sind einerseits bei dieser politischen
Frage andererseits bei einer
schwerinhaltlichen ich würde juli C
gerne fragen wollen die Sympathie der
Menschen mehrheitlich in diesem Land ist
auf der Seite der Bauern glauben Sie
dass die tatsächlich mit den Bauern
fühlen und denken was ja ein bisschen
dem widerspricht was sie am Anfang der
Sendung gesagt haben oder glauben Sie
dass das jetzt auch benutzt wird um
auszudrücken dass wir eben keine Lust
haben jetzt zusätzlich zu den
Belastungen eben auch noch on top für
diese Haushaltsprobleme zu zahlen also
ich würde jetzt sagen das zweite was Sie
gesagt haben ist richtig aber ich möchte
es völlig anders formulieren weil sie
haben gesagt es wird benutzt und man hat
keine Lust das klingt abwertenend das
klingt so als würden die Leute zu Hause
sitzen sich verweigern und sagen wir
wollen unseren Beitrag nicht leisten und
so weiter das ist es nicht sondern die
Stimmung ist glaube hab ich eine andere
und das ist auch nicht ganz richtig wie
Herr wüstees schildert dass das
sozusagen alles nur verursacht ist durch
die zugegebenermaßen schwierige
Koalition in der Ampel sondern auch das
reicht viele Jahre weiter zurück da ist
das Gefühl entstanden dass in vielen
Bereichen der Gesellschaft und es ist
nicht nur das Land sondern es ist die
Peripherie wir können auch Randlagen von
Städten nehmen oder die sogenannten
Problembezirke also immer Gegenden wo
Menschen wohnen die oft
einkommensschwächer sind die weniger
Bildung haben und die vor allem
miserable Infrastruktur zum Teil zu
ertragen haben schlechte Schulen
schlechter oder kein Nahverkehr
schließende Krankenhäuser und so weiter
die D mit Alltagsproblemen sitzen und
schon sehr lange den Eindruck haben dass
sie nicht gehört werden also das alles
immer schlechter wird es wird schlechter
und das regierungshandwerk konzentriert
sich auf andere Fragen natürlich weiß
man es gibt Krisen hererausforderungen
die müssen gemacht werden aber ich
glaube Gesellschaften brauchen um
friedlich zu bleiben wirklich so eine
grundpolitik die sich um die
existentiellen Belange kümmert die nicht
sagt dass es etwas sag kümmern wir uns
dann drum wenn wir mit dem dem anderen
fertig sind und der Eindruck ist glaube
ich entstanden dass der Blick dafür
verloren gegangen ist und diese
Protestwelle durch die Bauern richtet
man wieder den Scheinwerfer auf eine
betroffene Gruppe und ich glaube
deswegen schließt man sich dem an weil
man das Gefühl hat endlich macht mal
einer was endlich gibt es mal wieder
lautstarken Protest und jetzt werden wir
gesehen und das stimmt ja auch wir
sitzen hier heute Abend und alle zeigen
Verständnis für die Landwirte ich habe
echt gedacht ich sitze hier und alle
sind so oh und die dummen Bauern und ich
muss hier kämpfen aber alle sitzen da
und können es verstehen ja und ich
glaube dass das viele Menschen freuen
wird und dass sie sagen werden ja es hat
sich gelohnt es war richtig das zu
machen die Bauern deswegen
sympathisieren sie ja die Bauern und das
ist interessant sie sind ja eben nicht
alleine mit ihrem Ärger vielleicht
gucken wir uns das noch mal kurz an das
ist gesellschaftliches Problem geworden
wir haben kaum noch nachwuchst keiner
will mer den Handwerksbetrieb ausführen
weil wird nicht bezahlt in der Industrie
gibt's mehr Geld kein Beruf hat es gern
wenn er eine Leistung erbringt und er
kriegt sie nicht bezahlt wenn eben eine
gewisse Leistung nicht mer vergütet wird
dann wird sie eventuell nicht mehr
erbracht wir brauchen das Geld auch um
unsere Rechnungen zu bezahlen um unsere
Familie zu ernähren um der Betrieb im
Laufen zu halten
äh das war jetzt ein Arzt das war ein
Handwerker und es war noch mal ein Bauer
Frau Fiedler also dann geht es
tatsächlich nicht nur um die Bauern
sondern es geht um alle Menschen alle
hartarbeitenden Menschen die sich im
Grunde als die Leistungsträger
en in der Mitte dieser Gesellschaft und
unzufrieden sind ja also wir wir sehen
hier ein Unmut gegen die Ampel aber in
Teilen wird da auch ein Unmut gegen das
politische System auf die Straße
getragen von dem man sich nicht gesehen
nicht gehört fühlt und natürlich haben
wir jetzt gerade eine Situation wo
Energiepreise gestiegen sind wo generell
Lebensmittel teurer geworden sind und wo
insgesamt eine sehr große Unsicherheit
herrscht und in dieser Situation hätte
man gerne hätten viele gerne eine
Regierung die einen Plan hat und die
diesen Plan verfolgt und bei der Ampel
hat man leider allzu oft das Gefühl dass
dieser Plan eben nicht da ist Olaf
Scholz hat sich oft als einer
präsentiert der den Plan hat der weiß wo
es lang geheht jetzt hat sich aber
gezeigt der Haushalt ist geplatzt und er
ist nicht stark rausgegangen und hat
gesagt das ist unser Plan B so wollen
wir weitermachen stattdessen hat die
Ampel vier Wochen lang über
Haushaltskürzungen verhandelt und
das Chaos geht aber weiter und ich
glaube dass viele Leute das kirre macht
dass es einfach keine klare Richtung
gibt in die dieser Ampel das Land führen
will also dann ist man will ja den
Befund noch mal verstehen egal ob bei
der Heizung egal ob eben jetzt auch beim
Agrardiesel oder beim Elektroauto man
wird überfallen ist das eines der
größten Probleme man wird überfallen von
Entscheidungen vor die man gestellt wird
und vermisst eigentlich Verlässlichkeit
da ich vielleicht noch eins zum Befund
sagen ich glaube ich stimme Ihnen dazu
aber was hinzu kommt ist glaube ich eine
Diskrepanz zwischen dem was die Politik
verspricht und dem was sie dann liefern
kann firerweise Herr Öz sie haben wir
gerade beschrieben was sie sich wünschen
für die Bauern also eine Welt in der
auch kleine Familienbetriebe vernünftig
davon leben können ja äh ich finde wir
müssen aufpassen bei dem was wir
versprechen wir die Politik darf nicht
so viel versprechen auch von Olaf Scholz
kam ja mit den besten Absichten in der
Pandemie wird keiner zurückgelassen alle
werden schützt also die Politik tritt
auf und sagt eigentlich wir schützen die
Bevölkerung vor den Widrigkeiten des
Lebens das heißt natürlich auch die
Bevölkerung auch die Bauern die
beevölkerung ist nicht mündig sie man
kann ihr nichts zumuten sie wird
geschützt von der Politik und dann
stellt die Politik fest oh wir haben ja
gar nicht das Geld wir haben ja gar
nicht die Mittel wir sind blank und ich
also Verärgerung ist ja auf die
Differenz aus sagen mal Erwartungen und
Realisierung also ich glaube manchmal
die Politik muss vielleicht auch ein
bisschen ehrlicher sein un mal sagen
Leute es gibt bestimmte Situationen da
können können wir euch nicht helfen da
kann die Politik nicht alles abschien
ihr seid ja selbst die Politik wir sind
ja alle die poliit also ich finde das
total richtig was sie sagen vor allem an
der Stelle wo sie erwähnt haben dass die
Menschen als nicht mündig behandelt
werden das ist glaube ich wirklich ein
Hauptproblem weil die Ansprache zu sagen
ihr seid entweder dumme Kinder denen man
alles erklären muss oder man muss
geschlossen auftreten sonst glaubt ihr
nicht an uns oder wir müssen Euch aus
irgendwelchen Krisen helfen und euch
pampern die ist glaube ich vom
Grundverständnis falsch also Demokratie
funktioniert so dass Interessen von
unten an die Politik herangetragen
werden und oben überlegt man sich wie
bringt man das in Ausgleich also ich
glaube wirklich dass da ein Ansprache
Problemem ist die Leute halten viel aus
also zumindest gerade die Bauern wollen
nicht gepampert werden die sagen im
Zweifel die machen unseren Kram alleine
wir haben junge engagierte Leute auf den
Höfen die versuchen das Schiff am Laufen
zu halten aber dann lasst uns wenigstens
in Ruhe also legt uns einfach keine
Steine in den Weg ändert nicht ständig
die Bedingungen also man muss glaube ich
nicht denken ist ein großes Beschwer
auch gewesen mit wie viel Bürokratie Sie
zusätzlich jetzt auch mit wie viel
Auflagen neuen
auflagenbauern zu tun haben die Arbeiten
247 und es wird Ihnen ständig
unterstellt sie hätten sie sein keine
Fachleute und wüssen nicht wie man
Grundwasser sauber hält wie man also
überall genau und ja und es geht ja
nicht darum nicht zu sagen man muss mal
was ändern man braucht vielleicht einen
anderen Dünger man braucht andere
Energieform also die Bauern und auch
viele anderen Menschen im Land erlebe
ich nicht so dass sie sagen wir sind
änderungsfeindlich wir wollen einfach
gar nicht dass einer reinredet aber sie
wollen nicht behandelt werden wie kleine
Kinder und sie wollen auch nicht die
ganze Zeit von der Einrichtung in die
andere geschupst werden der Gedanke von
Herrn Fuß ist insofern aber interessant
weil der Bundeskanzler ja noch heute und
auch noch in dieser Haushaltssituation
sagte sie werden das in ihrem
persönlichen Leben gar nicht so
merken das ist ja auch noch mal ein Satz
gewesen der einem jetzt dann doppelt und
dreifach irg in den Sinn kommt ich meine
wie macht man wie macht man es in einer
Organisation wenn es was zu kürzen gibt
ich glaube der erste Schritt ist mal
dass man alle Beteiligten ernst nimmt
und sagt es ist euer Haushalt und wir
setzen uns mal zusammen wir reden wir
sagen so jetzt sind jetzt ist Betrag X
weg und jetzt müssen wir gemeinsam
darüber reden und verhandeln wie gehen
wir damit um und dann versteht auch
jeder ja Leute jetzt gibt's auch
Interessenkonflikte hier zwischen uns es
ist nie angenehm Mangel zu verteilen und
Kürzungen aber wir müssen sagen leute
ihr seid alle erwachsen das ist unsere
gemeinsame Organisation das ist unser
Staat und unser Geld das ist nicht das
Geld der Amt müssen überlegen und und
dann dann kann man diskutieren das ist
natürlich schwer aber hier entstand so
der Eindruck dass irgendwie da obskur
zusammen man zusammenaß man hatte
irgendwie nicht aufgepasst man hatte das
Urteil eine Nachtsitzung und dann wird
sowas rausgehauen und sozusagen es war
unklar warum warum wird dort jetzt so
massiv gesproch Problem wenn gerne auch
zwischen ihnen beiden und Herrn wüst
frage ich sofort ist auch ein Problem
wenn man tatsächlich aus einem guten
Zustand in einen schlechteren kommt also
ist das gar nicht geübt in der Politik
her Ö mir dass man natürlich den heißen
Herbst verhindern konnte weil in dieser
Krise wahnsinnig viel Geld ausgegeben
wurde für die energiepreisbremsen aber
jetzt ist das Geld eben alle und jetzt
haben wir deshalb einen heißen Winter
Fragezeichen und eine Situation die für
alle schwierig wäre das gehört auch zu
Ehrlichkeit dazu ich will mal sagen Frau
Z hat dir zurecht angesprochen wie die
Situation ist die letzten zwei Jahre
gab's diese Proteste nicht es gab
deutlich weniger Proteste wie bei meinen
Vorgängerin Vorgängern das hat damit zu
tun dass wir uns zusammengesetzt haben
verbindliche Verabredung getroffen haben
ohne dass die Landwirtschaft überfordert
wird aber man auch redet über die
Probleme die es gibt bei der envielfalt
beim Klimaschutz beim Tierwohl im
Konsens das Problem dieses Beschlusses
war man hat den Berufstand nicht
konsultiert ihn überrascht mit einer
Maßnahme die man nicht verstehen konnte
wen sie im Übermaß war und dadurch hat
man mit dem Holzhammer mal kräftig auf
die wunderschöne Porzellanschale gehauen
und jetzt müssen wir die Schalen
Zusammenwirken ein paar Sachen die
gemacht werden müssten ne das ist nicht
so ja aber da haben wir ja angefangen es
gibt jetzt eben das verbindliche
tierhaltungskennzeinen wir ändern das
Baugesetzbuch jetzt gibt's Geld eine
Milliarde für den Umbau der Tierhaltung
jetzt muss man sich drüber unterhalten
wie es weiter geht bei dem Thema Nitrat
das Sie angesprochen haben aber von
Brüssel eine Strafe von pro Tag eine
Million weil die Vorgängerregierung
einfach das Problem ausgesessen hat und
so getan hat als man das Problem im
Grundwasser nicht angehen müsste wir
müssen un halt ins Gesetz halten aber
ich weiß nicht wie ver tief wir jetzt
über Landwirtschaft reden aber ein Thema
was man nicht ausklammern darf sind die
Bodenpreise also die Preise die
inzwischen es kostet ein Hektar zu
pachten oder gar zu kaufen sind so hoch
dass kleine mittlere Betriebe sich das
Land nicht mehr verschaffen können dass
sie brauchen um zu wirtschaften eine
absurde Situation warum ist das so weil
das Land gekauft wird von großen
investitionsfirmen und nicht von der
örtlichen
Land Schut gestellt damit sie Jungbauern
bekommen damit sie die bekommen die
Landwirtschaft na ja gut wir regieren
halt auch er seit zwe Jahren aber lassen
Sie mich mE nicht die persönlich sondern
ich meine ne nein ich wollte noch mal
kurz was sagen einfach damit aus aus
Fairnessgründen ist ich bin großer Fan
von Fairness also ich habe ja nun
wirklich scharfe Kritik auch in meiner
eigenen Regierung geübt aber vergess man
mal nicht diese Regierung hat eine
Situation vorgefunden wo wir eine
Abhängigkeit von russischchen Gas hatten
bei ungefähr 60% wenn man nordstream 2
zu Ende gebaut hätte also zu dem
nordstream 2 1 zu bauen hat die
vogreierung beschlossen noch nordstream
2 hinzuzufügen um von einem Mensch wie
Putin abhängig zu sein bei der
energieversorgen man hat den
Kohleausstieg und den Atomausstieg
beschlossen aber den Einstieg in die
Erneuerbaren systematisch sabotiert man
die Netze nicht gebaut man die
Digitalisierung nicht vorangebracht die
Ukraine hat moderneres
digitalisierungsn aber
schon ja das mache ich aber schauen Sie
also wir haben es jetzt geschafft dass
ein LNG Terminal sonst 10 Jahre in 10
Monaten gebaut wurde wir beschleunigen
massiv aber ich wünsch ich könnte ih
widersprechen wenn wir das nicht jetzt
schnell ändern wird nicht übrig bleiben
was wir bei Digitalisierung
Beschleunigung hinkriegen s es wird
übrig bleiben dass wir uns streiten wie
die
kesselflieger nur den
radikal auch nicht Union es nüzt am Ende
nur den
Fanatikern es wird sie nicht wundern
dass ich ein anderen Themenvorschlag
mache Herr weil wir darüber tatsächlich
schon paar Runden hier diskutiert haben
mich würde interessieren warum
ausgerechnet die Grünen die Hauptfeinde
nicht nur der CDU CSU oder die
Hauptgegner der CDU CSU sind sondern
tatsächlich die Lieblingsgegner der
unzufriedenen sind in diesem Land sie
haben diesen Konflikt zwischen Stadt und
Land benannt sie haben in zwei
Interviews auch darauf aufmerksam
gemacht dass sie sich Sorgen vor
amerikanischen Verhältnissen warum
würden Sie sagen landen landet der Frust
der uns zufriedenen Menschen in diesem
Land ausgerechnet bei den
Grünen weil vielleicht so viele Städte
auch Grüne
sind und eine städtisch dominierte
Politik machen in der Kleinstadt geboren
auf der Schwäbischen Alb aufgewachsen
aber sie s Kreuzberger schon ein paar
Tage ja da wohne ich jetzt berufsbedingt
ab mein Wahlkreis Stuttgart den ich
direkt geholt habe
also ich bin Sozialpädagoge der landt
man senderempfänger wenn der Empfänger
was falsch versteht könnte es auch im
Sender liegen S ist immer gut wenn man
Selbstkritik übt und sagt wir haben da
sicherlich auch dazu beigetragen dass es
diese Vorurteile gibt ind dem wir in der
Vergangenheit vielleicht auch ein
bisschen äh sehr mit moralinsäure
Haltung durch die Landschaft gezogen
sind ich glaube aber mittlerweile ist
auch am Stadt das merkt mer dass Dinge
einfach komplett ins Gegenteil verkehrt
werden ich gebe mal ein Beispiel aus
meinem Bereich ich bin Vegetarier ich
kämpfe aber dafür dass die Tierhaltung
eine Zukunft wir weil ich sage es gibt
keine Kreislaufwirtschaft ohne
Tierhaltung ich sag sogar mein Gemüse
braucht Tiere und trotzdem wird überall
drauß transportiert der hat eine
geheimagenda als Muslim oder was auch
immer und will die Tierhaltung
abschaffen Herr höhes behauptet im
Fernsehen ich würde aus dem Kaffee den
Zucker rausnehmen es gibt einfach gar
kein Beleg dafür ich habe sogar gesagt
der kann Speckwürfel reinwerfen also wir
haben auch mittlerweile eine
Debattenkultur die richtig gefährlich
ist für unser Land sind aber bei der
analse warum ausgerechnet die Grünen ich
frag noch mal sie sind ein fr wir
diskutieren nicht mehr darüber wie wir
die Fakten interpretieren s wir
diskutieren darüber wie wir die die
Fakten richtig sind und da liegt kein
Segen drauf wie viel Wut haben sich noch
mal warum die Lieblingsgegner der
unzufriedenen wie viel Wut davon ist
auch berechtigt mit Diskussionen über
vegane Schnitzel über das lastenfahrad
über die sie können es selber ergänzen
ich glaube man kann da nicht so nach
berechtig und unberechtig entscheiden
weil letztlich sind Diskussionen über
egal was natürlich immer berechtigt und
ich glaube die Grünen sind zu einer
Metapher geworden da sind die zum Teil
Schuld dran sie haben es selber gesagt
es hat was mit moralinensäure mit einer
bestimmten Überheblichkeit zu tun wird
jedenfalls so empfunden inzwischen löst
es sich aber auch wirklich ab von den
real existierenden Politikern es ist
eine Metapher geworden für eine
bestimmte Haltung gegenüber Politik und
diese Haltung zeichnet sich dadurch aus
dass man Leuten nicht zuhört sondern
dass man eine eigene Agenda hat die
gerne auch als
alternativlos imprägniert indem man sagt
es geht um ein wichtiges Problem
Klimawandel Klimaschutz gibt sowieso
keine Verhandlung darüber und Leuten die
dann ihre eigenen Interessen ihre
eigenen Bedenken und so weiter da
einbringen wollen eigentlich immer
vorhält ihr habt's nicht verstanden ihr
seid zu dumm und so weiter und das hat
dazu beigetragen also das identifiziert
man jetzt mit den Grünen und zwar massiv
also ich kanne es ist wirklich schim ich
wollte eigentlich mehr noch mal nach
diesem woken stadtpublikum fragen ob sie
auch sagen würden dass der ländliche
Raum einfach völlig vergessen wurde und
dass es auch eben in extremen diskutiert
wird dass der stäter der W
diverse schlaue aufgeklärte Mensch ist
also ähnlich eigentlich auch wie
inzwischenweltten ja aber das sind doch
auch legitime Bevölkerungsgruppen ja
also wir können ja jetzt sozusagen nicht
einemen stäter auferlegen er soll
gefäigs aufs Dorf ziehen das ist ja
nicht sein Problem sondern das Problem
ist ja wie Politik und wie Diskurs mit
diesen Fragen umgeht ein Problem liegt
auch darin worauf Medien sich
konzentrieren also welche Themen liest
man denn wenn man die Zeitung aufschlägt
was kommt da eigentlich vor und wenn da
Schwerpunkte natürlich auf eine
bestimmte Seite ges werden hat die
andere Seite das Gefühl nicht gehört zu
werden ja wir sind ja aber gefühlt in
einer Art Kulturkampf also sie selber
sagen auch dass es eine sehr extrem
geführte Diskussion ist vielleicht ist
das noch mal auch eine gute Frage nach
Köln zu Herrn wüst ihnen kommt der Satz
natürlich auch nicht unbekannt vor dass
die Grünen da die Lieblingsfeinde oder
die Lieblingsgegner der CDU CSU sind der
geht ihnen nur nicht so von den Lippen
weil sie mit den Grünen ganz gut
regieren in nordrinwestfah
richtig wir regieren gut weil wir anders
regieren wir arbeiten vertrauensvoll
miteinander natürlich haben wir Wege zu
gehen zu gemeinsamen Lösung aber wir
wollen zu gemeinsamen Lösungen und den
Weg dahin den kultivieren wir nicht auf
offener Bühne und das ist der Kultur
Teil es gibt den inhaltlichen Teil von
der Politik aber auch die Frage der
Kultur des Umgangs miteinander
Landespolitik ist anders als
Bundespolitik zwei Partner ist
schwieriger als drei alles geschenkt
aber wenn man sich nicht bemüht Stück
weit Frieden zu halten eine gute
Debattenkultur zu haben ist das auch ein
führungsversagen man muss das klar so
sagen und vier Wochen zu brauchen bei
einem 470 Milliarden et um 17 Milliarden
einzusparen dem Kanzler zwei
Regierungserklärungen zuzumuten bei der
einen bei der zweiten was dann so
halbwegs geklärt hat auch was damit zu
tun dass diese Ampel einfach eine
grottenschlechten Umgang miteinander hat
bei all den Fragen wer was ist und wie
wir in Stadt und Land leben Nordin
Westfalen ist städtisch geprägt das weiß
jeder aber die Hälfte der Menschen wohnt
im kreisangehörigen im ländlichen Raum
ein bisschen mehr Entspanntheit und
Toleranz im Umgang miteinander wer vegan
sich ernähren will in dreigotts Namen
der soll es tun aber wer Fleisch essen
will so so wie ich das gerne mache der
soll doch bitte auch das tun und den
Leuten geht auf den Zeiger VC hat es
eben angedeutet dass Politik ständig
übergriffig wird gefühlt mit dem
heizungsgesetz in den Keller
einmarschiert so war das so war das
Gefüh mir auf den Teller mit mir auf dem
Teller rumfummelt das geht den Leuten
auf den Zeiger die Grünen kriegen das ab
es ist nicht sind nicht nur die sind
nicht nur die Grünen sind auch längst
nicht alle grünen so aber das ist eben
ein Stück weit auch das Verhältnis Staat
Bürger dass wir da in Summe vielleicht
mal wieder neu ausrichten müssen Herr
Fust hat es eben schon angesprochen den
Bürgern was zumuten ihm vor allen Dingen
aber auch Freiheit in Verantwortung
zumuten seine Entscheidung selbst zu
treffen ihn sehr ernst zu nehmen und
dennoch noch mal die Frage eben nach mal
Schnitzeln Gendern Diesel warum sind das
auch für Markus Söder und für Friedrich
März so Lieblingsthemen in der
politischen Debatte weil sie nichts
kosten und weil dagegen sein toll
ist das müssen sie die zwei schon selber
fragen es sind Themen die die Menschen
umtreiben die Menschen haben auch viele
andere Probleme aber auch diese Themen
weil sie symptomatisch sind für eine
haltungstaat Bürger kann man natürlich
adressieren W ist es gibt auch eine
Menge anderer Probleme und die zwei
reden ja auch über andere Probleme so
ist ja n nicht aber also man muss schon
sagen dass die Union auch ihren Anteil
hat in der Zuspitzung in der Debatte
also das dann ständig so getan wird also
ich habe jetzt die Ampel hier nicht in
Schutz genommen dieser Diskussion aber
das ständig so getan wird als ob Herr
ösem mir irgendwie den den Zucker ganz
verbieten will
oder als ob alle grünen sofort das
Gendern vorschreiben wollen oder das
Schnitzel verbieten das stimmt ja alles
gar nicht wird aber suggeriert und und
es passiert einfach weil die Union Teile
der Union das Gefühl haben dass man sich
in dieser Profil in dieser Polarisierung
auch profiliieren kann und dass man
hiervon profitieren kann aber ich glaube
am Ende geht das halt nach hinten los
absolut richtig nicht funktionieren und
dennoch die Frage ist das was also alles
richtig dennoch die Frage warum hat der
Bürger zusätzlich das Gefühl dass
ausgerechnet dieser deutsche Klimaschutz
so besonders teuer ist also auch die
Union müsste ja Vorschläge machen wie
sie eigentlich dieses Land Trans
transforieren werde ist gleich die
nächste Frage an Herrn büst weil im
Grunde geht es ja darum entweder in
einem deutschlandpakt oder nicht in
einem deutschlandpakt eines der größten
Unterfangen seit der Wiedervereinigung
zu schaffen nämlich die
Transition Transformation der deutschen
Wirtschaft hinzukriegen warum hat der
Bürger zusätzlich das Gefühl dass wir
das auf den kompliziert denkbarsten Weg
machen ich ich glaube zunächsten mal
gibt's da auch ein Gefühl der Ohnmacht
bei den Bürgern und das hat wieder zu
tun mit der mit einer Kultur die z.B
sagt listen to the signcience da wird
also so getan als würde Soz wäre
sozusagen wissenschaftlich vorgegeben
dass wir jetzt keine Ahnung 2030 dieses
und jenes Klimaziel erreichen müssen
dabei ist das ja alles falsch ne also
die Wissenschaft ist sich ja nie einig
natürlich gibt's gewisse
wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse die wir
auch ernst nehmen müssen das Klimawandel
vielleicht das größte menschheitsproblem
ist zusammen mit verfallender
atenvielfalt ich glaube das ist sehr gut
t aber wenn wenn Menschen sich anhören
müssen ihr wir brauchen euch gar nicht
mehr nach eurer Meinung zu fragen es ist
wissenschaftlich bewiesen dass wir diese
oder jene Politik machen müssen da muss
man glaube ich immer einschreiten und
sagen nichts ist wissenschaftlich
bewiesen was politische Entscheidung
angeht sondern politische Entscheidungen
sind politische Entscheidung wir müssen
darüber reden das muss demokratisch
entschieden werden und das ist glaube
ich der erste Punkt also die Menschen
haben den Eindruck dieser dieses
Programm der Transformation Veränderung
tut weh und uns wird erzählt ja Leute
wir haben das alles schon
wissenschaftlich ergründet wir müssen
Euch gar nicht mehr fragen wir wissen
wie es geht steht bitte stramm und wer
dagegen ist der ist ein klimaleugner der
ist moralisch ganz furchtbar ich glaube
da müssen wir erstmal runter auch auch
da glaube ich ist es wichtig dass man
den Leuten klar macht und sagt so wir
gehen jetzt den diesen Weg wir haben
politisch gemeinsam entschieden wir
wollen die klimziel erreichen das wird
was kosten Olaf Scholz ich will hier
nicht will ihn hier nicht wird schon
genug kritisiert aber der hat gesagt das
führt zu einem
Wirtschaftsboom da würde also wenn man
da in die wissenschaftlich Literatur
geguckt hätte hätte man festgestellt
nein das führt nicht zu einem
Wirtschaftsboom s das kostet wir müssen
auf was verzichten nichtsdestotrotz ist
das eine Sache die wir wollen die
Alternative kann ja nicht sein wir wir
machen keinen Klimaschutz in aber man
muss sozusagen schon dieses Problem
offen ansprechen sagen da wird auf was
verzichtet das kostet was wir machen es
trotzdem und so bewältigen wir es ist
die nächste Frage nach Köln Herr wüst
auch die Union muss ja sagen äh wie sie
diese
Transformation finanzieren würde also
fredich Merz saß hier in der Sendung und
sagte wir haben kein Ausgabenproblem
kein annahmenproblem sondern wir haben
ein Ausgabenproblem was ist denn das
Angebot der Union was ist das Angebot
von Ihnen wie man Klimaschutz besser
bezahlen besser organisieren könnte in
diesem Land damit eben nicht die Hälfte
der Bürger glaubt dass sie ständig hin
und her gejagt wird
innovationsoffen okay und mit einem CO2
Preis der den Experten vor Ort die
Entscheidung überlässt wie man dann CO2
einspart zu glauben man könne eine so
starke große Volkswirtschaft mit der
Mischung aus Verbot und Förderprogramm
transformieren ist leider ein
irglaube das das ist der Kern des
Problems warum den Leuten vorzuschreiben
genau in dem Jahr musst du das und das
in deinem Heizungskeller kommt do sogar
aus der entschuldig es komm ja sogar aus
der EU ständig neue Vorgaben und neue
Regeln das macht ja nicht
besser sie müssen mit Verboten Arbeiten
vielleicht na aber wir müssen nicht in
Deutschland immer noch einen draufsetzen
ich bin Ministerpräsident in einem
hochenergieintensiven Land und die
Wirtschaft spricht leider eine sehr
klare Sprache über diesen angeblichen
Wirtschaftsboom den Olaf Scholz sieht
144 Milliarden inv mittel sind im
letzten Jahr abgeflossen aus Deutschland
ins Ausland 11 Milliarden sind zu uns
gekommen das ist leider eine ganz
schlechte Perspektive insofern rate ich
dringend dazu im Ziel klar zu bleiben
das Ziel teilen wir wir müssen diese
Transformation schaffen wir müssen
Industrieland bleiben aber eben
klimaneutral werden völlig klar aber die
Art wie wir das anpacken muss sich
signifikant ändern innovations offen zu
sein niemand von uns Politikern die
aller wenigsten sind Ingenieure Angela
Merkel war Physikerin aber das war eine
Ausnahme wir wissen es alle nicht besser
als die Fachleute und es entwickelt sich
eine Menge wenn wir einen klugen Rahmen
setzen mit einer CO2 Bepreisung da bin
ich auch ganz klar die brauch es und das
wird eben auch Lenkungswirkung haben das
heißt wer sich nicht bewegt der muss
dann zahlen um das auch ehrlich zu sagen
aber das ist ein kluger lenkungsrahmen
und das ist dreimal besser als zu
glauben wir könnten das alles mit
Förderprogramm in irgendwelchen
Amtsstuben abwickeln das wird nicht
gelingen so und da ist nur die soziale
Komponente vergessen worden Frau Fedler
na beim heizungsgesetz ist die vergessen
worden zunächst jedenfall und bei der
CO2 Bepreisung ist es ja so dass die
ursprüngliche Idee mal war dass es dann
ein klimageld gibt also die CO2 Preise
werden hochgesetzt aber es wird dann ein
Stück weit auch an die Bürger wieder
zurückgezahlt dass was eingenommen wird
so dass die die sich klimafreundlich
verhalten dann auch was davon haben und
das erste wurde jetzt gemacht CO2 Preis
wurde hochgesetzt aber das klimageld
kommt nicht und vielleicht können Sie
Herr mir noch mal sagen was da jetzt
eigentlich der Plan ist weil eigentlich
war das ein Versprechen steht glaube ich
auch im Koalitionsvertrag insofern
müsste man sich da ja eigentlich drauf
verlassen können wir sind nach wie vor
dafür aber jetzt will ich mal sagen also
ich will ja ein wüst ausdrücklich
ausnehmen der ist ja sehr fair aber ich
meine schauen Sie wenn man das jetzt
ausschließlich über die CO2 Bepreisung
macht also quasi komplett die
Reduktionsziele nur über CO2 Preis macht
dann haben wir ein CO2 Preis da will ich
dann mal sehen wie die demokratische
Opposition im deutschen bundestagz steht
ich meine ich habe in badenwürtberg
gelernt als die CDU noch den
Ministerpräsident gestellt hat dass eine
gute Opposition immer mitregiert weil
sie Regierung im Wartestand ist die
Union im Deutschen Bundestag ist ja
nicht wie Herr wüst oder auch Herr
Günther in Schleswig Holstein s ich sagt
erstmal einfach grundsätzlich nein zu
jedem Vorschlag aber so kommen wir doch
nicht voran ich meine lassen Sie uns
doch ehlich sein Sie können es nicht
ausschließlich über ein CO2 Preis machen
weil der so massiv steigen würde dass es
soziale Verwerfungen auslösen würde
selbst mit einem klimageld das man erst
mal finanzieren möchten für das ich bin
übrigens um das sehr klar zu sagen es
gehört natürlich dazu dass wir die
Technologie nutz da bin ich ganz bei ich
komme ausum Automobil standandort
Stuttgart wir haben es Auto erfunden in
badenwürttberg sind wir auch stolz drauf
also geht's drum die antriebswende aber
natürlich geht's auch drum dass wir
schauen wie wir das Begleiten wie wir
das fördern so wie sie das übrigens in
Nordrhein-Westfalen doch vorbildlich
beim Kohleausstieg gemacht haben so und
das ist doch der entscheidende Punkt
dass wir DAF ein Rahmen haben wo wir die
Leute mitnehmen dass wir beim
heizungsgesetz Fehler gemacht haben ich
meine das war ja jetzt glaube ich sehr
deutlich zu spüren da haben wir hat
dafür bezahlt und jetzt machen wir es
und eigentlich wollte man so einen
Fehler nicht noch mal machen die Frage
ist ist das noch mal ein Fehler geworden
fr C ich wollte so gerne hören was er
sagt darf er
zuerstür viicht nur kurz zum CO2 Preis
das glaube ich wegen ein sehr wichtiger
Punkt also die Vorstellung es wird
billiger wenn man den CO2 Preis nicht so
hoch setzt das ist ein großer Fehler und
ich glaube das hat eben Herr Herr
habbeck gemerkt im Fall des
heizungsgesetzes also es gibt so diese
Vorstellung nein wir dürfen den CO2
Preis nicht zu hoch werden lassen wir
machen lieber ein Verbot und eine
Regulierung man man entlastet die Leute
dadurch überhaupt
nicht
Frau aber aber in dem Fall glaube ich
ist schon wichtig was er wüst gesagt hat
der CO2 Preis muss das Zentrum sein ich
bin bei Ihnen Herr özem das ist nicht
alles wir brauchen aus verschiedenen
Gründen brauchen wir weitere Maßnahmen
aber nicht weil es dann billiger wird
sondern aus anderen grüen entschuldigung
dass ich sie unterbreche obwohl wir
Ihnen ja gerade so gerne zuhören sie
sagen das ist verrückt sie sagen auch es
braucht sonderschulden wir schaffen die
dekarbonisierung wir schaffen was war es
noch nicht ohne zusätzliches ohne
zusätzliches Geld ob man das nicht das
Ende der wel ob man das jetzt klimafond
nennt oder ob man es Sondervermögen
nennt sie sagen wir brauchen um dieses
Ziel des Klimaschutzes zu erreichen
ähnlich wie Herr Hüter ähnlich wie
andere Wirtschaftswissenschaft wir
brauchen zusätzliches Geld na ja genau
wir brauchen zusätzliches Geld natürlich
kann man das Erwirtschaften auch indem
man weniger konsumiert man muss jetzt
nicht in Schulden gehen nur gibt's dafür
nicht die Bereitschaft und es muss auch
nicht unbedingt sein was ich mir
vorgestellt hätte jetzt in dieser
Situation jedenfalls wäre dass man in
der Tat sagt wir haben ich glaube darau
besteht Einigkeit wir haben erhebliche
investitionsbedarfe nicht nur für die
klimatransformation für die
Digitalisierung für die Infrastruktur
denkt man ans
Gesundheitswesen riesen
riesenversäumnisse und da könnte man in
der Tat sagen okay wir setzen uns
zusammen als Opposition und Regierung
machen einen Sondervermögen das hat ich
unmittelbar im Anschluss an das Urteil
vorgeschlagen wir machen ein
Sondervermögen das heißt wir verankern
im Grundgesetz wie bei der Bundeswehr
eine sonderag vererschuldung da bräuchte
man die Union ist der Gedanke von Herrn
östemier jetzt kommt er auch von Herrn
Fust und wir fragen Herrn wüst in Köln
denken sie dass von der Union noch mal
so ein Angebot kommt darüber nachz zu
denken ein Sondervermögen klimaion die
Union ist ja anders als Herr öst mir es
gerade dargestellt hat eine konstruktive
Opposition die Hälfte der Beschlüsse des
Bundestages rund die Hälfte wird mit
Zustimmung der unionsbundestagsfraktion
gefasst beim Sondervermögen für die
Ukraine für die Bundeswehr
nach dem Überfall hat die hat die
Bundeswehr hat die Bundeswehr die
Unterstützung der Union auch bekommen
und die Zustimmung kam für diese 100
Milliarden friedich Merz war zwe mal im
Kanzleramt leider außer Spesen nichts
gewesen aber es lag nicht an Friedrich
März der den deutschlandpakt Angeboten
hat die Länder Ministerpräsident auch
viele von der Union dabei haben mit der
Bundesregierung eine Vereinbarung
getroffen in der Migrationspolitik die
leider der
umsetzungageig und insofern kann kann
uns niemand vorwerfen wir sein da als
Union nicht konstruktiv beim Schulden
machen sind wir sehr sehr sehr
zurückhaltend und auch zurecht denn es
wäre doch sofort Tür und Tor offen wir
sehen das bei den 100 Milliarden
Bundeswehr verabredet war nur
Neuausstattung auf einmal werden andere
Dinge damit bezahlt aus dem laufenden
Betrieb das ist nicht in Ordnung und
deswegen sind wir zurecht als gebrannte
Kinder als
unionsbundestagsfraktion als Partei in
Summe skeptisch ja man kann mit uns über
kluge Lösung immer sprechen aber die
Schuldenmacherei ist nur wirklich nichts
was man mit leichter Hand betreiben
sollte jede generat ja es ist immer eine
konkrete Frage morgen heute ist es dies
morgen ist es
die m auch an die Z
denenz mitgeben darf ich schätze sie
sehr wissen Sie sie wären noch ein
Zacken glaubwürdiger wenn sie auch noch
hinzufügen würden dass das kaputtparen
der Bundeswehr auch
Verteidigungsminister waren die nicht
mein woll nach vorne
gucken Sympathie Beier Sympathie auch
nicht ersparen dass die frühere
Verteidigungsministerin und
Bundesvorsitzende der CDU Kamp
karenbauer schwer gescholten worden ist
in der großen Koalition von Frau esken
als sie das 2% Ziel angemahnt hat das
ist bis heute nicht erfüllt das hat n
wahlich nicht an der Union gelegen nein
nach zwe Jahren Bundesregierung muss man
mal aufhören immer den anderen die
Vorwürfe zu machen da muss man mal
selber die Verantwortung übernehmen und
ich bin sehr sehr zurückhaltend jede
Generation muss das was sie ausgibt auch
selbst erwirtschaften brauchen wir einen
klugen Rahmen blauen wir bauen wir einen
klugen Rahmen verhindern wir dass jedes
Jahr 144 Milliarden Euro
abfließen es ist Kapital in Deutschland
da schaffen wir einen klugen
Investitionsrahmen fließt privates Geld
in diese Investitionen es muss nicht
immer Staatsgeld sein kein Staatsgeld
was wir als Schulden aufnehmen der Welt
reicht wenn der Investitionsrahmen nicht
sauber aufgesp m europäische Gesetze
erfüllen ich wollte an der Stelle
tatsächlich nur anmerken dass ja auch
noch eine FDP mit in der Regierung ist
also da ist die eine Frage was die Union
machen würde ob die so ein
Sondervermögen Klima mitmachen würde
aber eine FDP würde SAS ja
wahrscheinlich wir reden ja jetzt gleich
über Neuwahlen wir reden nämlich darüber
in welcher Situation so fingen wir an
das Land atmosphärisch übermorgen sein
wird Schlussrunde juli was glauben sie
wird am ja was wird aus dieser
Protestwelle wird es so sein dass sich
nach dem Erreichen einzelner Ziele für
einzelne Branchen in diesem Land die
Menschen wieder ins Private zurückziehen
oder wird es ein vielleicht ziehen sich
ins Private zurück aber damit ist uns
noch nicht gedient also es reicht nicht
diesen Protest zu befrieden sondern wir
bräuchten wirklichen Wechsel im
Selbstverständnis von Politik wie wir es
angedeutet haben mehr Verantwortung an
die Bürger mehr Vorsorge für die
existenziellen Bedürfnisse undut
ralismus mehr absolut gar nicht in
freien Rahmen für selbstverantwortliches
handeln also ein Rahmen der es vorgibt
aber der den Leuten Freiheit lässt das
brauchen wir unbedingt und eine andere
Ansprache Schluss mit Augenhöhe
doppelwums und so ja also alles was nach
Kindergarten klingt muss weg sachlich
erwachsen er ich auch mal was
unangenehmes aber immer mit dem Gefühl
es ist unsere Politik nicht die da oben
machen irgendwas mit dem Land sondern es
ist unser gemeinsames Ding was wir hier
irgendwie in Griff kriegen müssen weil
sonst drohen uns diese amerikanischen
Verhältnisse die auch sie angemahnt
haben wir sind viel viel näher dran
glaube ich als wir manchmal denken
würden her wüst sie sind schon wieder
dran Neuwahlen die ihr Chef ausgerufen
hat denn etwas an dieser Stimmung sofort
verändern glauben Sie ein Neuanfang
würde etwas
verändern aber Neuwahlen wird es nicht
geben weil sich die Ampel in nichts
einig sind aber aber dass Sie das nicht
wollen da sind sie sich einig dass sie
keine Neuwahlen wollen darin ist sich
die Ampel einig wenn sie auf die
Umfrageergebnisse und Werte schauen Herr
östem mir sind sie wahrscheinlich
genauso erschrocken wie alle Politiker
in dieser Ampel welche Konsequenz ziehen
Sie daraus könnte es tatsächlich
Realität werden dass man nicht nur
Europawahlen erleben wird am 9.06
sondern es auch Neuwahlen gibt nein das
muss wir jetzt auch nicht herbei
beschwören sondern die Ampel muss jetzt
endlich mal aufhören sich mit sich
selbst zu beschäftigen sondern das was
sie eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht
macht das vernünftige nach vorne bringen
und wenn ich das auch nur sagen darf und
die Opposition da hat er wüst ja recht
beim Thema Bundeswehr und Ukraine Gott
sei Dank stehen wir zusammen das gibt's
nicht in allen Ländern in der
Europäischen Union aber es wäre halt
auch gut wenn die Zukunftsaufgabe
Klimaschutz eine wä wenn die z.B jetzt
die Frage wie gehen wir mit der
Landwirtschaft voran wenn auch da wir
jenseits von 51% gegen 49% mal wir haben
keine Mehrheit mehr in der Ampel ich
will gar nicht sagen wie die
Beliebtheitswerte der einzelnen
Politiker äh sind es gibt keine Mehrheit
gerade für die drei ampelparteien im
Deutschen Bundestag sie kennen die
Zahlen der AFD wie sehr besorgt Sie dass
diese Partei mittlerweile bei 22% in
ganz Deutschland und bei über 30 in den
Bundesländern ist im was soll ich sagen
wie jeden Patrioten jeden das jeden der
Deutschland liebt und will dass es
diesem Land gut geht muss es besorgen
denn wir wir wissen um was für eine
Partei es sich handelt man kann sie
jetzt gerade nachlesen wiitte welche
Geheimpläne sie machen übrigens in der
Landwirtschaft muss man wissen im
Grundsatzprogramm steht drin dass sie
nicht nur Kfz-Steuer Agrardiesel alle
Subvention für die Landwirtschaft
abschafft und trotzdem gibt's ja Leute
im ländlichen Raum die in der AFD ein
Hoffnungsträger sehen auch da bin ich
wieder Sozialpädagoge ich sehe da die
Verantwortung auch bei uns die Ampel hat
jetzt durch den Streit leider nicht
geholfen aber auch die Union hilft nicht
in dem Sinne Sprache benutzt die haben
sie ja gerade benützt die am Ende doch
gar nicht bei der Union einzahlt und die
zahlt ein bei den radikalen Rändern das
ist ja nicht nur die AFD das ist Frau
Wagenknecht das ist her Maßen wie die
alle heißen die dieses Land von ihnen
kaputt machen wollen und wir sind jetzt
einfach aufgefordert als Demokraten das
Land in der mititte zusammenzuhalten
sonst drohen dieses Jahr Ergebnisse wo
Fanatiker
radikale in die Exekutive kommen
Apparate mitbestimt stell sich mal vor
die haben Kontrolle über
Verfassungsschutz die haben Kontrolle
über Polizei die hab haben Kontrolle
über Gerichte immer da muss doch Angst
und Bange werden wir haben bei Trump
gesehen dar man darf sich das ja schon
eine ganze Zeit vorstellen oder besser
gesagt man muss sich das schon eine
ganze Zeit vorstellen die Frage ist doch
wann antwortet Politik darauf und wenn
sie jetzt darauf verweisen dass die
immer mehr Zuwachs bekommen und was sie
tun die Frage ist wie sehr ist Politik
schuld daran dass die AFD zu solchen
Zahlen kommt ja natürlich sie schuld
dran also ich m unterscheide auch
zwischen den AFD Funktionären und ein
Teil der Wählerschaft es bringt nicht
die Wähler zu beschimpfen sondern ich
glaube wir müssen schauen dass wir
diejenigen die da noch nicht sind nicht
weiter dorthin pushen und verlieren
Stichwort ländlicher Raum und wir müssen
gleichzeitig denjenigen die vielleicht
nicht bei der AFD sind weil sie ein
geschlossen rechtsradikales Bild haben
sonder weil sie sauer sind über
Politikstil weil sie sauer sind dass wir
ländliche Räume vernachlässigt haben den
müssen wir durch gute Politik begegnen
und da ist ein wichtiger Bestandteil
hingehen ich versuche das ja
ist nicht immer Vergnügen
steuerpflichtig augen auf bei der Berufs
Wahl aber ich glaube das ist der einzige
Weg der hilft nicht über die Leute reden
mit den Leuten reden und V allem viel
zuhören und dann auch zugeben wenn man
was falsch gemacht hat da fällt kein
saacken aus der K ist interessant ich
glaube mir hat heute abend ziemlich
viele gute Analysen gebracht und wenn
die Ampel sich daran halten würde an das
was sie heute Abend gesagt haben dann
wäre schon vieles besser bloß am Ende
passiert es eben nicht so ne sie sind
aus Sachsen Frau Fiedler das darf ich
verraten da liegt die AFD mittlerweile
eben auch vor allen anderen und über 30%
wie fällt ihre Analyse da
aus ich glaube das ist wirklich jetzt
ein Schicksalsjahr
2024 also wir haben jetzt Umfragen
gesehen wo die AFD bei 37% steht wenn es
dumme Konstellation gibt dann können
schon 40 42% zur absoluten Mehrheit
reichen und dann sieht's wirklich düster
aus und da ist eben ein Teil sie haben
es gerade genannt der Leute die sind
rechtsextrem die wollen das so und ein
anderer Teil ist einfach unzufrieden
fühlt sich nicht gesehen nicht gehört
und dann diese Leute muss die Ampel ran
oder muss es einen anderen Politikstil
geben ich glaube die Ampel braucht jetzt
einen anderen Modus des Regierens der
Vertrauen Z rückgewinnt der
Verlässlichkeit ausstrahlt der erklärt
was gemacht wird der aber auch Erfolge
rausstellt die es ja zweifels ohne gibt
die offen kommuniziert und gleichzeitig
wie Frau C sagt den Leuten was zutraut
auch
Zumutungen ja kommuniziert und sagt das
muss jetzt sein weil und gleichzeitig
aber ganz viele in der Fläche präsent
sein ich glaube da sind ganz viele
Rezepte da sie haben es angesprochen
muss jetzt gemacht werden und viel Zeit
ist nicht schaff man das in vier Monaten
ist die Frage es sind gerade schon
angeklungen es gab perfüst
Veröffentlichung eines rechercheagazins
Korrektiv die herausgefunden haben dass
sowohl Unternehmer als auch
Rechtsextreme als auch AFD Politiker in
einem Hotel in Brandenburg diese
remigrationspläne
schmiedeten AFD Verbotsdiskussion ist
sofort wieder im Raum was halten Sie
davon diese Partei zu verbieten eben
weil sie diesen rechtsextremen Strang
hat ist das Demokratie fördernd oder
hindernd ich glaube mit Verboten muss
man vorsichtig sein stellen sich mal vor
der Verbotsantrag scheitert dann hat die
AFD noch das Gütesiegel
verfassungsrechtlich geprüft um Himmels
willen wir müssen uns damit
auseinandersetzen warum so viele Leute
frustriert sind und ich habe es eben
schon mal deutet das Thema
Migrationspolitik ist in diesen Wochen
etwas in den Hintergrund geraten wir
haben einen Beschluss aller 16
Ministerpräsidentin und
Ministerpräsidenten mit dem
Bundeskanzler das ist ja nur wahlich
keine homogene Schar da sind
Sozialdemokraten dabei Christdemokraten
grüne ein Linker bitte W vorsichtig und
bessere Politi wir müssen Probleme wir
müssen Probleme lösen und das
migrationsthema gehört dazu dazu habe
ich eine Allianz der Mitte vorgeschlagen
über diesen Winter Problem jetzt zu
lösen mit den Dingen die wir in
Deutschland machen können mit einer
Zustimmung zu den Dingen die in Europa
auf dem Tisch liegen wenn die Zahlen
wieder hochgehen im Frühjahr und sie
werden wieder hochgehen dürfen wir bitte
nicht überrascht sein und die Diskussion
von vorne beginnen sondern müssen
Lösungen haben und dann kriegen wir auch
die AFD und Frau Wagenknecht wieder
dahin wo sie hingehören nämlich unter
die 5% Ende dieser Sendung und wollen
ganz kurz von östem mir wissen wären sie
für ein Verbot der
AFD bin kein Jurist ich verstehe da
nichts von aber wir haben die AFD schon
mal klein gekriegt die AFD war vor 2015
schon mal kleiner sie ist danach noch
mal runtergegangen da stimme ich ja wüst
ich glaub das Thema Migrationspolitik
gehört dazu die Leute müssen das Gefühl
haben wir wissen wer ins Land kommt wir
wissen was mit ihnen passiert aber es
geht auch um das Thema Infrastruktur es
geht um das Thema wie wir Politikstil
machen und es ist ja nicht Gott gegeben
dass die AFD diese Ergebnisse hat das
kann man ändern und ich glaube wir
müssen es ändern wir müssen nur aufhören
uns vor allem miteinander zu beschä und
mehr mit den beschäftigen die das Land
kaputt machen wollen an dieser Stelle
danke für die Diskussion hier in der
Runde und danke nach Köln an diesem
besonderen Abend wir sind dabei jetzt
ganz rasch zu Markus l überzugeben der
Jens Spann zu Gast hat sie wir sehen uns
wenn Sie mögen nächste Woche wieder
gleiche Stelle gleiche Welle sie kommen
hoffentlich gut durch die Zeit und hier
im Saal noch mal ein herzliches Dank bye
bye tschüss
[Musik]